هو احد العملاء الاستخباراتيين الاكثر
شهره تاريخيا لكنه مختلف عنهم فهو لم يخدم
النازيين لانه نازي ولم يحظى ببيت كبير
ويختن برجوازي حتى ان احد لم يكرمه بل عاش
حياته متنقلا بين المهن المتواضعه ثم مات
وهو مفلس انه الياس بازنه الملقب بشيشرون
فما قصته ولد الياس او الياس بازنه في
اقليم كوسوفو البانيا كان والده مالكا
للاراضي وكان جزءا من تيار موال لتركيا
كذلك كان والده وعمه اعضاء في حركه يانغ
تركس وهو في الرابعه عشره وخلال الحرب
العالميه الاولى احتل الحلفاء كوسوفو
فانتقلت عائلته الى اسطنبول وهناك التحق
باكاديميه الفاتح العسكريه ثم بوحده عسك
فرنسيه بتركيا لكنه ما لبث ان اتهم بسرقه
اسلحه وسيارات بريطانيه لصالح الحركه
الوطنيه التركيه التي كان يقودها كمال
اتاتورك حكم على الياس بالاشغال الشاقه
لثلاث سنوات عمل بعدها بمهن متواضعه كعامل
او سائق وغيرها بعض هذه المهن كانت لدى
جهات مهمه في تركيا وفرنسا كجهات
دبلوماسيه وقنصليه حيث استفاد الياس من
مهاراته باجاده اللغات التركيه والصربيه
والكرواتيه والفرنسيه في عام
1943 تم تعيين بازنا خادما لدى السفير
البريطاني في تركيا يونايت بوليوغاسن خلال
تلك الفتره جرى اتصال بينه وبين رئيسه
السابق البرجينغ حيث حاول استغلال قدرته
على الوصول لوثائق يحتاجها الالمان
في السادس والعشرين من اكتوبر عام
1943 ذهب الياس الى السفاره الالمانيه مع
وثائق قال انه يريد في مقابلها عشرين الف
جنيه استرليني ليصبح بعدها وكيلا المانيا
مدفوع الاجر استمر الياس في تصوير الوثائق
وارسالها للالمان الذين حصلوا على امكانيه
وصول مباشره لمكتب المفوض السامي
البريطاني قام بتصوير وثائق بريطانيه
عديده بحوزه السفير كان من اهمها وثيقه
قائم بيجت وهي اعلى وثيقه امنيه لعمليه
غزو نورماندي كما نقل بازنا معلومات مهمه
حول مؤتمرات قاده الحلفاء بما في ذلك
مؤتمرات موسكو والقاهره ثم مؤتمر طهران
الاهم حيث اجتمع الرئيس الامريكي فرانكل
روزفيلد ورئيس الوزراء البريطاني وينستون
والسوفيتيو جوزيف ستالين فاستلهم من خلاله
الالمان خطه الاغتيال فشل ضد القاده
الثلاثه علم البريطانيون بوجود جاسوس يعمل
داخل السفاره التركيه فحققوا معه لكنهم
فشلوا في القبض عليه وهو يبيع المعلومات
الاستخباريه فتوقف عن عمله بحلول نهايه
فبراير عام
1944 وغادر السفاره في غضون شهر بعد الحرب
تم استجواب الخادم بتهمه ارتكاب جرائم حرب
حيث حاول شراء وتشغيل فندق في انقره من
عائدات حياته المهنيه في التجسس التي كانت
عباره عن عملات مزوره دفعها له الالمان
خلال عمله فتم سجنه بتهمه تداول اوراق
مزوره بعد خروجه من السجن عاش الياس في
انقره مع اسرته لسنوات عديده وعمل في مهن
متواضعه مجددا ثم انتقل لميونخ عام 1960
وعمل حارسا ليليا قبل وفاته عام
1970 بسبب مرض الكلى نشر الياس مذكراته عن
عماله تحت اسم شيشرون عام
ورويت قصته ايضا في كتاب ايجن سيسرو وفيلم
5 فينجرز
1952 وفيلم شيشرو التركي